so now we know the humans can agree
now we just got to put it in something
no my wife just called me i'm sorry
please everybody
my wife said mars how do we stop him
from chewing socks and other people's
things
how do we stop him from doing that
listen in new york city they got people
in
a one-bedroom apartment people got
tigers in their apartments
yeah alligators tigers they got busted
because the alligator and the tiger got
the fight and he tried to break it up he
got bit the chunk taken out
and they found out hey marv mars
mars russell is not going to like it
what do you do when they do this stuff
you stop them
i've never had nobody to hump you that's
what i'm saying it's like it's a lot of
pen top humping
[Music]
welcome back to hop boxing we are here
in paradise i'm jeremy piven
and i'm mike tyson and i'm season milan
yes
baby all day and we're eating what
guacamole
and drinking um palomas here we go
it's a little bit got the mexican
passport on you got delgado
there you go mario lopez loves it
but that's what we call it pinion yeah
we call it palomas
so you you've created your own paradise
here
you know um when i came to america
uh i wanted to become the best doctor in
the world i was i grew up watching
lasting ranting team
so i thought that all the dogs were just
like last year and renting team
yeah right so i say i'm gonna go to
america
i'm gonna learn from americans and then
i go back home you know
because mexicans we don't go too far
from home or mom
right so but then when i saw the
situation in america
about this connection and the lack of
communication and that we're not
creating trust respect and love
and i said i need to create a place
where people can come and learn
natural simple profound when people can
actually understand
energy and the psychology of a dog
because people were
treating a dog like a human you know
what i'm saying so if you change
the way dogs learn if you change the way
things are
you're not going to be able to create
what you're looking for which is that
honest integrity loyalty there's some
good [ __ ] man
for real mike you didn't trust it you
didn't think he could make guacamole
i get my guacamole from the goddamn
launch truck
yeah yeah i don't know diving guacamole
they tell me they told me it's a
superfood so i go eat guacamole i don't
care where you get it from a super food
i'm gonna get in the ghetto wherever
they start
[Laughter]
but you come from a culture where that's
that's you from the north of mexico so
we
we got the good food yeah we got the
good seafood
we're known for the food you know what i
mean so you
did you when did you know that you had
an insight
into this whole world oh the the animal
dogs yeah
i grew up on a farm in espalino sinaloa
mexico
and my grandfather said never work
against mother nature always gain their
trust always gain their respect and
they're gonna give you a beautiful
gift called loyalty so i grew up with
those moral values
you know i didn't know i had a anything
to offer to the world
uh i knew that i had the passion you
know which is
i wanted to work around animals and
especially dogs
you know until i came to america i
realized that i can offer
the knowledge that my grandfather
nurturing me
you know otherwise i had no idea because
i didn't think our dogs were
extremely connected you know watching
lasting writing thing you would think
wow those dogs are understanding english
you know what i mean so that naiveness
at that time i didn't realize that i had
anything to offer
that's why i came to america but america
definitely allowed me to
to to know who i am in a professional
world right
yeah but i mean there had to be a moment
where you realize
wow i know how to connect there's you
know you know how to break through at
all
but that's when so i used to live in
englewood uh
in englewood to south central so my
first dog psychology center
i started in nine nine 919 east 61st
street
in in south central in the hood okay
right so they used to call me the
mexican guy who walks a pack of dogs
because i used to walk rod wireless
pitbulls and german shepherds off leash
40 of them
i didn't know i didn't know i didn't
know it was illegal to walk off leash
you know dogs i didn't speak english i
didn't have
you know papers or anything like that i
believe you kids no they just say you
know what i mean because
they they just told that i was crazy i
guess so
so so that's when i start you know
people
i started looking at me different you
know that's a mexican guy
you know that walks a pack of dogs so
you should go call them
and that's okay so i got something going
on here i was just walking dogs because
that's all i knew
it's all you knew but how do you think
you've always known this
i mean that's the part that's the part
that
you know that once you so that what i
love about america is how much they love
dogs
right so the value of a dog is another
level
i was getting ready to express do you
know how many wealthy people when they
die they left their fortune to their
dogs
yeah can you believe that yep lady live
well i don't mention the plane lived
next to me dude
neighbor minds i was like no that's love
listen
you lock you lock somebody say a
girlfriend a wife in a
trunk and you let your dog in the trunk
and leave him there for a day and open
the door so you'll be happy to see you
i remember that right yeah yeah you're
happy to see what
what are we playing unconditional love
listen it's so hard for people to even
conceive of that for other people even
though they say they loved
them and they married them you've seen
that in acts of people
um sacrificing their life for love is
very rare
yeah yeah it's very rare yeah
yeah so that that that's actually to to
to experience love at another level
after each other it's really a trip
which which i seen people like throwing
birthday parties for dogs
dogs get to see santa claus in america
i've seen dogs getting married
you know what i mean i never see that in
them in mexico right a dog
you know it's in social space a dog is
to protect the home
that was back in my time you know now
people have changed their mentally
thanks to the show
but uh but the uh well we lost
we look for that we receive on the
underdog and that's the trust and
loyalty
yeah well we've lost that's what we lost
because now everybody has a price
no everybody's pricing that money but
they have a price
you know and that's the thing with a dog
it's not about money fame and power it's
about natural simple profound
so that's so what i said about energy
the energy you have right they don't
know
they don't know mike tyson as mike tyson
they just know what's his energy
we had you know at one time in life man
had
been rolling with a pack of lions
there's no way that couldn't have
happened it had to happen
you see how domesticated they had them
now imagine the beginning of like
history you know time they had to roll
together there's no way they had to
hunt with one another yeah that sounds
crazy there's no way that
have happened or the cheetah cause the
cheetah is more like a dog than a
and a matter of fact the late legendary
ancient kings used to hunt with cheetahs
right you watched some pigs they had
cheetahs hunting
hunting the boards wild boars so they
could do with cheetahs
and they probably did it with lions too
and and then they took
dogs the rhodesian ridgeback
yeah how is that possible what
to teach a dog to hunt a lion
those are the boar balls the the
radiation rich packets for a different
type of but it's the same i mean it's
hunting right but uh
but it's it's the thing is look you can
you can create a dog to a border collie
to just do that right that's the amazing
part of humankind
right that we can actually grab a
specific behavior
and and grab a specific uh target
and and create a breed specifically for
that
but we don't do that anymore right so so
then that dog that was bred for that
now lives in the city with no jobs
he said so the dog in america has become
unemployed even though he hasn't
a degree right so once you get a
purebred dog
what you're getting is a dog with a
degree right so
okay fine we're not out of work it's out
of work so so make mistakes
like an instagram model still make
mistakes but the reason why it makes
mistakes is because
it doesn't have his energy put into work
so what i do what i done for that is i
created a backpack
so when you take a dog for a walk you
put a backpack on that's a job
you see it you need to give a dog a job
to give a dog a purpose
you have one here a backpack for dogs
yeah yeah i'll send you with one before
you leave for it for one second
yeah yeah so the point is no matter what
breed the dog is like the boy scouts
right so kids who is a boy scout no
matter what race the kid is
he carries a backpack right and now he
has a mission
right so anything with a mission
anything with a purpose becomes a job
can you get it so so once you have any
purebred dog
that's why a lot of people say well it's
easier to deal with mutts yeah because
they don't have that
specific ability to to
to achieve a task right you know a
labrador is labrador a german shepherd
is a german shepherd
they're all dogs but they're different
breeds so we all
humans different race it's fascinating
it's in their dna
yeah it's been bred into it yeah you
don't have to teach a dog how to swim
you don't have to drink a dog
it's like pigeons um say this um for
instance i put
why is one pigeon worth two dollars and
one worth two million
why that's true i don't know you know
why
because who his mother was or who his
father was it's not incredible
it's because who their family bloodline
was because he was 2 million this guy
was two
dollars 252 million
please tell me you didn't ever pay two
million dollars for a pigeon but that
wood is worth it
i love it me too yeah i understand that
because
that's it you you're getting perfection
this is perfect
okay it's perfection yep in a minute
so so what would the characteristics of
a two million dollar pigeon be like what
what could that pigeon do like a koi you
know sometimes
you know what sometimes they trace them
back from the crusades
bloodline how much you think that'll
work um
but that what they they trip
back there
wow the dog that he wants uh you know
the tibetan mastiff was sold
for a million dollars a puppy
oh million dollars but he comes from
like 400 years old generation
of tibetan mastiff you know so it's just
you're buying the generation you're
buying the
same thing just um lucky sperm club
yeah you know lucky sperm club
absolutely yeah but i never heard about
that you don't know
i actually have heard about that what
about what the bitching's looking good
look it up look it up yeah no it's paid
for a pigeon i
met a koi there was a million and a half
million dollars mccoy beautiful
white and thailand it had to be
something different what was so special
about that well
number one first of all was the the
color it was
perfect white and the round red circle
on top
perfect just freaking perfect the guy
has his own pawn
no that's it they show him they
transport them in his own plane
and he goes to do and these people are
so proud of him listen um do you know
something
you know what are the um the stalks
pelican like the stalks
they eat um they eat koi fish
no no not that one that's the chicken
yeah i have to have koi fish i have to
put a net i put a net over the pond i
got koi fish right there yeah cause they
come to eat them
the stalks so it's kind of fascinating
because you
i had originally reached out to you
because i was not
connecting with my dog my dog was giving
me attitude
my dog would take one look at me and
just go i own you
that was that was a look my dog was
giving me yeah he would look at me like
just totally not not interested that's
mars
yeah so you've got the same problem with
your dog
that's because you let them my my
history with dogs and my relationship
with dogs
the reason why i i don't i never really
particularly kids with like dogs
but i had my cat that was related to my
and um
they're my conscious like before anybody
even comes right comes to my house
my dog or my cat they're right there at
the door
before i can't even hear them before the
president even drove their car there
they noticed somebody's coming right
right you know they could hear and tell
do things that we could never even
imagine doing you know and they could
see
things and hear things that we could
never imagine hearing yeah and i always
think this is my conscience that's what
i say about my dogs
interesting good way to look at it but
it's sensitive i always tell somebody's
coming to my door before they even ring
the doorbell
well of course so your
initial contact with the dog is
everything
when i go to people's home
you us as dog owners we establish that
relationship and if we
if we show them too much
love without it being unearthed there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with the
love it's just the order of
so so first you have to gain the trust
the respect and then you give them the
love
trust respect a lot right so i believe
it's an order for things
so it's a formula of rituals and symbols
so to be a champ there is a formula
to be an actor there is a formula you
know what i mean is body mind heart
not just because you love to be an actor
you're going to be an actor you know you
have to put the body the mind the heart
it's an order of things yeah so we know
that
anybody that has accomplished things no
the investment of the body and the mind
is first
you have to gain the trust of respect to
the people so they can give you the love
yeah you know what i mean not just
because you're somebody or whatever
you're going to get loved right away no
you're going to earn it
we all know that but when it comes to a
dog people say no
just give them the love but that's how i
end up with a tv show i didn't came to
america to have a tv show
you know what i mean i came to america
to learn
from americans so i can go back home and
open my own business because i wanted to
be a vet
but because i come from a low-income
background my parents couldn't afford it
so the next thing to work in the
behavior of dogs
where can i go and learn there's no one
in mexico at that time
you know there was that i can actually
want to follow
you know and could be my role model so
you had to
you you had no examples you had to kind
of carve out your own path
yeah i became the first whisperer in the
world right
yeah now now a lot of kids want to be
that
so i created my own profession you know
i created my own path
i created a uh a dream for a lot of
people and i created this is the first
dog psychology center in the world
nobody has this yeah no there's no no
way in the world this is the first one
you know uh so obviously you know
i called that temple the temple of
dreams over there
it was my vision to become the best in
the world i just didn't know i was going
to become
cold the dog whisperer you know i was
going to stay in america
and then uh help generations of people
to uh
to connect in a natural simple profound
way yeah you know what i mean and
and i just i you know travel the world
and do
live shows all over the world i have to
learn english of course
and and and to speak english and to
teach people you know
in in their language wow about who they
already love
because america already loved dogs they
just didn't know
dogs so one thing is you love things but
if you don't know how and then
you just have an idea you know
right you have to make it reality you
have to make it tangible
and the only way you can make it reality
intangible is body mind
you have to execute what's inside your
mind
even if nobody knows what the hell
you're talking about
right no you have you know i train
people rehabilitate dogs what is that
means
everybody's taught before they came that
you're supposed to train the dog
and i said why would you train a dog
when the human doesn't know anything how
can a human be a good teacher when he
does he's not being trained
you know what i mean yeah knowledge and
then is the affection
did someone train you or you kind of how
did you
no that was just me that was just no
nobody there was nobody
to look for you know there was no no
role model to look for
you know hey do you think i'm doing it
right yes
so speaking the right thing you know
they throw around that word gift
a lot right right but it was a gift for
you yeah that way
it's a mission it's a spiritual mission
yeah absolutely that's why i like all of
that stuff you know because it's
it's part of that mission it's part of
that knowing getting to know yourself
without all the crap that you that you
pick along the way
you know because you know you attract a
lot of things
and then that pollutes who you are so i
want to know who
am i without any toxicity of the world
my environment
parents you know sinaloa mexico
and the border and whatever whatever
happened
i want to see myself without all of that
calm comfort love and joy i want to
i want to see that part of me without
that huh without all that
i want to see myself without all of that
with animals the reason why
i love animals so much is this look at
this
so this place my goal for this place for
people to come here is to feel safe
peace and love as soon as you walk into
my land i want you to feel three things
safe
peace love for me i want you to get calm
confident love joy
and then i'm gonna give you the
information how i got there right
you see it i mean yeah yeah i definitely
feel that being here
and it's interesting because you also
along that way became famous
are you here for fame i know but then
you have to navigate that
yeah and that's a whole other animal
tell me about that
you could ask mike about it tell me
about that that's right oh no
in situations like that you have to see
it's like you can't let fame imprison
you you have to liberate yourself from
yourself
yeah but you need your knowledge yes you
need knowledge
the world's a big school it'll teach you
i know but before you get to the real
teachers
you go through the dark you know what i
mean and so
i have a foundation you know seasonal
foundation and my goal is
for the next generation america is to
understand
how to stay connected because you're
born connected you're born
wanted you want you wanted to be calm
you won't want to be confident you're
born wanted to love you want to want it
to joy
to spirit is joy you born wanting to
feel safe
you want one to feel peace and love
you're born all of that so it's not
something that you have to go to school
to to achieve it you are born with it
but if your role models do not nurture
in nature that
and then unfortunately you're going to
lose it so yes you can become
money fame in power but doesn't mean you
are happy
no you see it doesn't mean you're calm
doesn't mean you're you
you love doesn't mean you have trust
respect and love so then what happens is
you have to go back and
and you know reconnect to your real self
that's why people go to india and people
go to peru
yeah they go to find themselves the
enlightenment thing
but you born your spirit before your
flesh
you can find all that wherever you are
you should yeah
you should i think the whole world
should bring all that to you
you can bring all that to you you could
summon all that to you
it's already in you yes yes you're alive
so since you're alive you're spirit your
instincts and your heart
what you what you don't have before you
arrive
is the intellect you don't even know
what your name is going to be you don't
even know what language you're going to
speak
and if they call you they're going to
call you a white guy black guy mexican
guy
you don't know you just know that you
want to be safe peace love trust respect
love honestly tell your loyalty
calm comfort love and joy and you know
you have to use your body your mind and
your heart
to move forward in life you know all of
that is instincts
it's spirit it's hard you know what i'm
saying but when somebody
doesn't nurture nature that and then you
lose track of it and then you start
looking in the wrong places
for guidance right because when you're a
kid you're looking for somebody to
follow
right because at that moment you can
only follow you can't lead
right but if you have the wrong role
models if you live in the wrong
environment
and then you start absorbing the wrong
energy uh behaving the wrong way
and yes you can become money from in
power but at one point you want to go
back
to your spirituality to your instincts
into your heart
that's why i love animals so much yeah i
just think um
animals like people just have to have
the right experience on
what they engage with the right people
the right energy
because i at some point in my life there
was no way i was going to turn out
to be who i was i was going to be shot
killed caught aids
there was no way i was going to turn out
to be here with you
and i just think anyone can change the
person the dog i don't believe i just
believe
anybody could change when they prepare
the chain that's right that's right you
well that's what i call calm surrender
so once so once you enter into your calm
surrender state
that's when transformation begins so
your most powerful state of mind
is not happy-go-lucky or calm confident
it's your calm surrender because that's
when you listen
you learn and you heal so most people
have difficulty with the work surrender
yeah you see what i mean because they
see it as weakness but surrender means
open mind
and calm body calm surrender
so when i teach a dog or when i help a
dog i just help them get to that place
that's why i do exercise first i calm
the body
i attract the mind as the mind opens
nose eyes ears that's why words are
everything yeah
it's a great um they're really they're
just their everything where's everything
how we perceive the word that's right we
perceive this right most of the time we
perceived them wrong
that's right we're not used to having
encounters with those words that's right
really perceived
i tell you what's near about words
because i english is not my first
language
so i started hearing the words dominant
right dominant
so tiger woods dominated the court
so i tell the dog people oh you have to
be more dominant and then some people
will feel
offended i don't want to hurt my dog
wait a minute
the lakers dominated the court right so
you see it so it's
so it's semantics what i mean is
i didn't invent the word i didn't mean
the language i'm just okay so you don't
want me to use that okay
what words are american okay
with the with the leadership position uh
assertive
they didn't like it either what about
confidence
i don't know you see what i mean so it's
like listen choose the word
that you want i just want the feeling i
just want you to feel
calm and positive so you call it however
you want
because the dogs don't care what you
call it what the dog care is how you
feel
so if you're not calm confident you're
not gonna lead
you're gonna go back in the pack you
can't lead in the animal world they
don't follow instability
we're the only species that follow
unstable leaders and
yeah something yeah only animals follow
stability so
i was saying earlier to jeremy if you're
not the highest communist
if you're not the highest positive if
you're not the highest love if you're
not the highest joy
you can't say i want to lead the pack in
the animal world
you can don't even don't even like
register yourself to be a president yeah
they don't they won't choose you
and you can't lie to animals about how
you feel
because it's weight it's like it's
impossible a little bit
it's impossible right it's like waves of
energy they're gonna pick up on they
don't have the rationality so they can
care less what you wear
what you call it you know whatever
however they
they it's like saying can you can you
lie to god
no you can't no you can't you can't no
you can't
you can't lie to an animal and you can't
lie to god well listen god dawg
backwards
we never try to lie to animals that's
one thing humans never lie to with
animals you imagine that
oh my clients [ __ ] beat a lot
of animals
what i've never lied to an animal i like
you because you have animal knows all my
dirt
everything i ever did my bird's nose
that's why your dog doesn't like you
mike oh god
i don't care he likes it
yeah no no you can't lie it's impossible
to lie to someone who has doesn't have
rationality
yeah you know what i mean he just sees
right through you
right it's like when you go to tsa and
you you get this metal detector
well the dog detects your [ __ ] like
that
or a rat or whatever it's so interesting
because
basic some basic stuff that you do right
away
that i do sometimes instinctively with
dogs but sometimes i don't
which is just to hold on to your power
and and and you know be very calm
and they will sense it they'll come to
you yeah you know but the moment you try
to like
fanboy out for instance you they haven't
earned it right like you're on your
hands and knees you're doing that stuff
and they're like no i got this guy yeah
this is and they're all out of his
pocket my dog runs my house he's in the
mood i can't
i can't sleep my wife he sleeps in
between us it's just his house
talk to him caesar talk to him
my wife don't want him to change i mean
that sounds good
that's different that's different yeah
this guy's a
he's not a dog he's a child he's a child
right you understand he's a child now
yeah one day listen one day sudden had
my wife went outside and
one night she closed the door i forgot
it was doing something she left mars
outside
the whole house was a heartbeat the
thing that we lost to it was uh
the whole house was quiet um it was just
one of the
the thought of it and i jumped in the
car and my daughter jumped in the car
and yesterday that we both was in the
car he was looking for this crazy dog
that was just next door
hanging out with his friend but the fact
that our house all changed the whole
energy in the house changed once we
thought that possibly we lost though
yeah yeah the dog makes you human the
animal makes you human
you know definitely they have family
back guys
yeah the trip huh yeah yeah
what what do these dogs know
that we don't realize they know do you
know what do you mean
i mean we all make mistakes with these
dogs
because we don't realize go ahead sir oh
no i think we don't know god like they
know god
our perception of god i think they have
a clearer perception of
for their perspective than we have for
ours this is my opinion
i like it i like your opinion because i
believe on that
i definitely believe on earth and god
are
connected you know we need to experience
uh ourselves our home and and our
families
in a very genuine way in a very honest
way a very respectful way very loving
way
so if you connect to that vibration and
then you align
yourself to that you know vibration yeah
you just hit on it yeah you you connect
yeah it's like a 5g or 4g is which one
are you vibrating that you connect
that's why you know the tony robbins in
the world the pack choppers of the world
what their help trying to help humans is
to connect to a vibration so you can
achieve your vision yeah
you see anyone saying they help hundreds
of thousands of people correct but only
with the ones they connect the other
ones are like cheerleaders
you know what i'm saying exactly yeah
but but so i was 13 when i say i want to
be the best doctor in the world
you know so i said it to my mom and
because my mom agreed with it
and then that created the vibration of
accomplishing
right then when i was 21 that's when i
said mom i'm leaving where are you going
i'm going to america
i'm going to go because you know i have
to be old enough enough for my mom to
let me go
and so that's when i moved to the border
and that's when it took me two weeks to
jump the border
and then i was homeless for two months
after i closed the border
but it's that vibration is that that
focus that vision that trust
i didn't speak english i didn't know
anybody i didn't have an address i
didn't i didn't have money
we come from low income family but my
point to the world
is that if you connect to that vibration
and then
whatever you want in life comes comes
free so if your goal is to have a dog to
walk off leash
just connect to that vibration my
clients that's all they want
they can't see their dogs walking off
leash like what we see homeless people
walking with the dogs off leash
they can't see it because they're afraid
so if your insecurity
if you fear controls you your hesitation
controls you
you can vibrate at the level that nature
vibrates because animals are not born to
be
on a leash we're the only species that
put things on dishes on everything
you see what i'm saying they're born to
follow you willingly
willingly not because you make them but
i understand i understand it's a leash
law
but it is a way where you can teach
where the animal feels calm comfort love
and joy
with that leash but most people do you
want to go for a walk
and then the dog goes super excited and
the dog you can't control them anymore
no
it's so interesting you're dealing with
people who
their lives are fear-based so you
introduced a couple words
and they were that word offends them
right
dominate no no bring it down please no
dominate
confidence too much what right you know
what i mean that's all fear-based
and we're dealing with a culture that's
dominated by that i didn't mean to say
dominated
but nobody but but dogs aren't they're
not dealing with the
language or any other and so they just
see okay what's
what's this energy what's this vibration
and they gravitate towards it
what's the energy and what is the
activities and then the repetitions
right because i i want you have to
repeat so it's your energy your
activities your repetitions
so calm confident love and joy exercise
discipline affection every day
then they say follow play explore
because the dogs can only do three
things they follow they play or explore
kids follow play explore but it's an
energy
activities repetitions i i like to say
things in three because it's easy to
remember
yeah you see what i'm saying says follow
play explorer that's it you follow
somebody somebody's following you you
play with somebody
they're right and explore follow play
explore
everything's in threes even comedy is in
threes so three is
yeah it's very powerful yeah it knows
eyes here's the other side's nose
honestly loyalty you know i i'm i don't
mean to interrupt no no
but um since we learned this ice always
thought sense of my opinions i've been
doing
some 11 10 years old and i just believe
what from information i received now
that i'm 54 i just think that um
they were born for us to take care of
them because they can't take care of
themselves
who are the [ __ ] they die within the
year 18 months
damn in the wild there's no deadly 17
years where
someone takes care of them 17 years yeah
the birds 16
17 but it's just um why are these birds
here you know what i mean everybody was
thinking why are there so many of them
if they're not supposed to be here
that's why it's always good even the
ones in the streets
i just always hate i just do my races no
they ain't no purebred
but they the purebreds come from these
birds right you know i mean that's just
just the ancestors but i'll tell you one
thing mike i'll tell you one thing
i rather i rather rescue a dog from the
streets of mexico
or any tour country than a purebred dog
why
because that dog knows everything he
knows how to cross the street he knows
how to tell you
i'd rather have one of those i just have
to become a friend of him
and then eventually for him to follow me
and that's it i don't have to put him on
a leash i don't have nothing
he will teach you the streets street
smart right exactly but you get a
purebred dog you still gotta teach them
freaking streets you gotta teach them
what not to pee or not to touch you know
this street dogs
retain the instincts
uh a uh uh a dog that was bred and then
you have to train him and blah blah blah
blah blah
you have to tell them what to do three
dogs
they're bad ass yeah that's why you have
dogs when you have house dogs
if [ __ ] really gets bad a street dog
will leave you
the house dog's not going to leave you
because he depends on you no mm-hmm
i don't agree the street dog is
independent like you say he could do
without you
if you die you can get someone else the
street dog can the house dog can't
but once you gain the the the loyalty of
that you're right
that dog depends on himself the truth is
animals don't eat us because they can
find food water shelter family
they don't need us you know what i mean
a kangaroo doesn't need you an elephant
doesn't need you and well doesn't need
animals that do happen eaters they don't
like how we taste
they don't eat us because they're really
desperation
so i found out they don't like sharks
and bears don't like him in being flesh
i don't blame them it's like we're still
full of dog sex it's like the terrorists
full of toxins yeah we're not organic
we're not heir one
or gals i'm gonna kill you though they
want to kill you they don't want that
but that's because you enter in the
wrong place
because you're bothering their territory
and they feel trend to their family
you know what i mean when when a shark
or a or a bear or
lion hurts a human or kills a human
it's not because he's looking for that
human like i spent with sharks before
you know like the hunters i was with
sharks i hung out with sharks before i
heard that how did it go
beautiful were you afraid before
absolutely
yeah yeah absolutely but i'm one of
those guys anything i'm afraid if i do
it
right well let's and then i'm afraid if
i'm afraid if i'm afraid to ask this
girl i'ma do it
whatever it is right that's the
self-esteem thing we were talking about
landsat with the dog
yeah and they don't like the taste of
our flesh so they don't want to eat us
but when you flail around and the fear
manifests into that behavior
that's when they're going to take a bite
they think that you're a seal or
something
oh the sharks yeah yeah i mean you're in
the wrong place
bears just attack anything that moves if
they have children they don't have that
they have no prejudice whatever moves
but they have cub they attack
you have to do nothing it's attacking
you yeah right let's see let's protect
this go out at you yeah right at you and
they say with a shark
if you pee on a shark they'll go away
but you can't you found the piss i well
that's the whole thing you have to be so
calm can you imagine being so confident
that you could
can you imagine peeing in the water in
the water what do you want to do
goes the other way but
but the but the point being you you have
to get into a place of
completely eradicate any type of fear
right which you would be almost
impossible and then once you can do that
they'll go away
right which is insane but what i was
told about someone that's been
taught attacked by a shark a [ __ ] he
says um
before it happens it's just um dead
silence
yeah and before it happens it's just
you'll hear birds you don't hear nothing
dead silence the birds and everything
must be aware that he's around so that's
why they
take off but he says dead silence you'll
hit nothing
then it attacks yeah well when they're
hunting there's
they're quiet so when a dog is you know
i see a lot of people
walking their dogs and they're going to
a hunting mode you know what i mean and
that's why it's not good to walk a dog
in front of you because you put them
into a hunting mode
as well tracking mode hunting mode
pulling mode so a lot of dogs just
walk around they're scouting for dogs
so it's this silence so when you're when
i'm reading a dog
is you know as people call me and say is
my dog aggressive no your dog is hunting
which is even worse because aggressive
dogs
you know they're expressing themselves
with a little bit of sound a little bit
of movement
the guys who are hunting
they're scouting for it so that so you
open so the dog is a domesticated
species
but the steel hunters so the whole point
of
that you're not supposed to allow is to
bring that instinctual side of hunting
that's why it's very important for a lot
of people not to play tiger work with a
dog
before you get the breaks like the rules
by the limitations
you know because when you open that you
bring in that side
you know and what's the squirrel where's
the squirrel that's killing
something you're giving permission to
get excited right
he said so because a dog lives in the
city now you don't want to
have an excited predator he's a predator
right you know and you're always looking
for balance
if you're saying they're not in front of
you they're right next to you or they're
behind you yeah and you're
you're establishing that first first so
the handicapped people
are doing it right you know they're
blind but the dog is next to them
uh homeless people just don't have money
paying power or at home
the dog is on the back of leash so the
handicap and the homeless are the only
two humans in america
who are doing it right my clients put a
harness
a a a flexi leash and the dog is just
all over the place
so that is why they're never going to be
able to take the dog off leash
they have uh um fights and accountants
in the sidewalk because the dog
is he already pee and all the trees that
he just passed
you see it so for them to pee as
ownership
you know so the other dogs come in the
opposite direction like this
why are they so fascinated with pee it's
almost like they're reading emails
when they they're just like that tells
you who they are that's right
any and for example you know um they get
all their information mars that is
intact
they will know that he's intact and he
has a sperm and their pee
so then they will start they get all the
information they're also calling females
that way
they're you know they're they do it guys
so happy mars i can't believe he's this
happy
where is he right there yeah
i'm so happy to see him like that have
you tried this one
no i stick with this all i've taken so
like oh okay this is this is hot
it tells me to eat this this is going to
make me a better person
with a little avocado on it okay isn't
that funny food can make you a better
person
i believe you it's happiness wow
that little little in the kick has a
little kick now it's not
just enough i never taste a kick on this
before
yeah little jalapeno in there that's
good yeah that's good
get a little bit of lemon how far are
you from the um
[Music]
the places that you order foods from uh
how far is the uh firestone or whatever
we ordered the food from
stone okay i i found this coming
i found this to be a very um
isolated place this one yeah that's
pretty isolated
not really isolated i would like to be
where i'm at now from
newport beach to l.a i'm like an hour
away i like that this you're like
30 minutes i like that hippo [ __ ] is
far
yeah yeah you just have everything you
want to you have to go to los angeles
you know
you like it never i've been in newport
beach oh man
number one another in a million years i
used to be younger and my twins of us
never in a million years but they said
hey man you all look at all those white
people and stuff
never the millionaires think i would
love this place they would give me all
the wrong information all these years
right right now i'm up there they can't
get me away from me right can't get me
it's interesting you know people telling
you who
you they think you won't like yeah
another million years thought to have a
dog live up there
especially the labradoodle i love it
yeah change my this dog change the whole
family dynamics yeah
dogs um allow it brings compassion
in the house as well empathy compassion
no doubt about it yeah
people see you with a dog and they see
you differently
with me and anyone with a dog
oh yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean
yeah yeah look i can i can we can be in
a meeting with
jewish muslims catholics christians
whatever you want you put a dog in it
everybody talks about the dog
it's not the home you have no
discussions getting a little bit heavy
with your wife
stop walking yeah stop stop isn't it
yeah the energy is getting
is it's a great mediator it's a great
you know i've been with republicans
democrats whatever you call it
it's all about the dog yeah you know the
dog is the family the dog is the heart
it's funny you could be on stage you
could be the best actor in the world
if a dog wanders on stage everyone
looks at it what does he do it here yeah
you've lost yep you've lost everyone's
attention that's right that's
kind of fascinating it's not pure that's
that genuine pure
you know um it's like a little kid
it's just just genuine honest and
totally present
in whatever you know whatever he doesn't
know he's you know ruined the scene or
anything like that it's just
i just feel like running i just feel
like walking that's fascinating i just
feel like rolling
i thought french montana had i did uh
yeah they want he was yeah it's a bit
massive
i got so jealous why i want one of those
things man they i think
so that's a good energy whatever he has
that's a good energy that's absolutely
yeah i love this energy
he's super calm that would be perfect
for for mars
yeah that dog right
he yeah great energy that though i want
a dog like stop my wife i let my wife
seen that so we can get a dog like that
for mom yes remember fighting like hell
for this dog in the house
there's a war going on in my house right
now for this bad mastiff
as we talking about the war going on
right now
how how big do these dogs get 75 huge
75 no 170 175 yes no not 75
like the best that's 40 right what's
that 40 i think
175 75. and that's muscle
oh this is a beautiful yes it's huge
it's bones
but tell them about the beauty of the
dog this dog is so beautiful
god yeah it's like a small tiger a lion
i mean
lion no that's a small yeah a small lion
it's huge small lion why do you think
you wanted to get a
tiger a tiger why did you think you
regret you gravitated towards one
uh early on all down my insecurities i
guess
[Music]
it's powerful you you wanted to be seen
that way
huh you wanted to be seen with a tiger
no i wanted something that ferocious to
love me
um that's pretty cool
that ferocious to love me that's
weird huh mm-hmm yeah yeah why you want
somebody ferocious to love because
he can never love himself he's alone all
the time if he meets a woman that's not
breathing time he's going to kill it
he's going to kill her
he doesn't want you to look at him if
you look at him if you see your eye
connect with how you're going to kill
you don't want you anyone to be alone
and i want that to love me exactly 100
wow imagine that's what my ego was when
i had my cat
wow wow no one can come around me
my kids nobody
how old was he what did i get i gotta
what
a couple of months you probably lived 14
years wow
and you were you were able to hang out
with her for even when
the only time i ever got bitten by cat
ribs i was giving this
line a goddamn um
shot and he bit me but um that's the
only time i ever got
um hurt by a cat yeah you could have a
cvd before you get that shot
yeah i'm taking the shot okay give him a
technical shot
so i mean that's kind of insane yes it
is
no it was the right one because a lot of
people i know was killed or bitten by a
cat and stuff like that
or somebody in their family was trying
to give him a hug and attack cat
attacked him or something i heard a lot
of stories that you had to wear masks
because if you walk
behind them they grab you you know so uh
so i
ran into a cat you said the energy i
can't believe i had a cat like that
you can't but you can't hang out with me
so
but what was your energy then huh what
was your energy when you were around the
cat
like to get in you like the cat is right
there and
how did you just first accept it at
first time i had the show i was strong
and all that stuff and then there's just
pure and it was wrong it was just pure
love
she was the boss too oh damn she was the
boss of the house too
yeah yeah it's the same there's people
nobody don't know
you're scared to be physical because you
think when he gets older he's going
remember that get back at you so you
just want to show love and then by doing
that he makes mistakes too because
then he he knows that you're not going
to do nothing if he gets somebody else
so everybody else is the target pretty
much so you knew instinctively when you
first met this cat
you couldn't show any fear i didn't
think anything about failure so madly in
love with fitting them into my mind
right
sometimes and i had to learn about the
cat world because sometimes
you have your cat your cat is different
you can't go to somebody else's cat and
go
hug in somebody else's cat you can't do
that that's why i've
learned that the hard way in the cat
world you have to feel them out just
like this and then the guy was hey
you can go in there now yeah but dogs
would like the same treatment
yeah you know what i mean the dogs would
like to say like respect come on give me
respect let me gain your trust
right and then we can be friends trust
respect the death
but people with the with the cats and
the horses yeah like horse people like
no no you can't just
run into the horse you know become even
if
a horse person is going to teach a child
how to be with with a horse
they tell them to become keep distance
invite
don't let them invade trust respect but
the same principles can be applied to a
dog
and those are the same principles you
apply to yourself you don't just want to
love a bra
when you want to gain the trust you want
to respect the person right you know and
then it's the love
trials respect love yeah absolutely you
know what i mean it's like but with a
dog people just want to break all the
rules and then they blame the dog that's
the part
that's the part like when people say oh
pit bulls and rottweilers and german
shepherds
and or simply they just blame the dog
there is no knowledge behind instincts
it's all reaction
so you can't blame someone who reacts he
doesn't blame the lion he doesn't blame
the tiger he does
he you you won't they don't rationalize
how can you blame somebody who does not
rationalize
right why would a dog be any different
you see the media is always going after
the pit bulls the road writers the
german shepherds in the 70s
people were afraid of the doberman in
the 80s people were afraid of the
rottweilers
and then in the 2000s people were afraid
of the pit bulls so every 10 years
whatever breed is popular and powerful
they blame it
but in the 60s were the german shepherds
because they were used for civil rights
right so choppers dobermans rottweilers
go dating back to the knights go back
there they want to get touchdowns
holocaust that's right you see what i'm
saying but it but it's not the breed my
point is not the dog
it's not the breed it's the human behind
that
absolutely because lassen renting thing
is a german chamber
from the little restaurant pretty much
got stigmas just like human races
exactly you know exactly so right now is
the mexicans
back there was you guys the pit bulls
and stuff yeah exactly right now the pit
bulls
so the funny part is is the dog whisper
and and uh and
my my right hand was a pit bull so it's
a pit bull and a mexican changing the
world
but you they never say oh it's a mexican
and a pit bull changing the world
no he's a dog whisperer guy with his dog
daddy
[Music]
i would like to have that title as the
mexican guy look
to change the world yeah because that
was really what i'm saying but
but then however they manipulate it i
love the opportunity though
salute salute
but when we're all americans we almost
lose our race
yeah when we come on when you're in
america you almost you know there's
there's just um there's so many races
only it's the marriage
it doesn't even it's just something it's
a human yeah you know what i mean yeah
with different cultural animal
dog breed we have our own life we have
american language that's right i mean we
have english language we have american
life
is that a trip and a little bit of
culture because it's not a long it's not
a long
you know culture out of the words that
are now in this that
guys our age probably invented them
during our era and stuff 70 words like
came in back into existence with the
hip-hop era too that's right
hard rock all that music error yeah a
lot of words came into existence from
that stuff
yeah i mean it it it depends on your
background like i i grew up
in a in an integrated culture and
there's not a lot of
truly integrated cultures that you can
grow up i was the only white boy on my
football team
i didn't know any different we hung
american football america
american football so you hung out with
people because
you connected with them that's right for
no other reason that's right
and so that's i have a very different
perspective and that's my perspective
life and that's
the way it should be it's not always the
case unfortunately but that's education
yeah that's the knowledge part you know
so kids have to learn at an early age
that it has nothing to do with debris
as long as you understand energy you
connect with the animal
as long as you connect you understand
the psychology of that particular specie
dog knows ice ears and then doesn't
matter the breed the breed is just a
cultural background so do you want to
do you want a dog to retrieve well of
course you get a labrador they naturally
do it
right you know you want a dog to protect
but you get a rottweiler a german
shepherd or that
they naturally do it you see it but if
you just want to just have
a companionship and connection and
relationship just get a mud
get get a mixed dog it's it's perfectly
fine
so what do you what kind of advice would
you give my dog died recently
what kind of uh advice do you give how
old was it he was he was young man
he was not not even quite four years old
died in my arms do you jump right back
in do you take some time what what is
what is it well it's grief
right yeah el dia los muertos is us you
know so we mexicans we celebrate death
so we don't stay too long on the
unhappiness
you know you know so so you have to go
to the grief
because if you bring another dog to try
to to
to fulfill or to heal he's gonna find
you uh
in pain right so then because you're a
human and pain you can't really lead
you see it so i might as well just honor
your grief you know what i mean i don't
even
i can't even imagine something bad
happening that moment that we thought we
lost our whole house changed
wow that one second we thought she was
he was going
the whole [ __ ] house changed
everybody was that guilt we were mad at
my wife
just to hold that second so quick yeah
so [ __ ] quick yeah it was glad it was
over
all the things that you're saying about
dogs are the same about humans
yeah you know what i mean yeah you have
to know yourself you know
in order for you to enter into different
relationships
uh assess and evaluate what relationship
you're about to enter
as your tone scale as long as you're in
a calm comfortable enjoy
do it but if you're not there don't do
it
just don't hey you ever came to some
kind of
even some fixed conclusion that these
guys could be people that we
once loved and stuff and came back
checking out
but because sometimes i think like past
life yeah bugging something
flying or flies and they're saying mike
it's me [ __ ] mia it's my
daughter that's my love
it's me and i go get away from me you
know i kill it
i think that all the time that's
probably my mother right there you
stomped on
yeah i don't kill nothing i don't kill
anything i don't care if it's
a bug stick me a b i don't kill anything
don't kill anything
the best of my ability he'll kill
nothing yeah an animal makes you human
empathy compassionately that's like love
i i do believe what you just said yeah
i believe that you know the body dies
and the spirit continues on
even where does it go that's right even
though i know we're all religious we are
different
god is too comp religion is too complex
yep you know i got to dislike somebody
to be
in one with god it's just too complex
that don't even make sense to me
in that perspective that we have to kill
people right make god happy i just don't
understand
that it could be true but my mind just
can't find
my mind but that's why the pack walk
that's why all the different species
that we went for for a walk it just
shows you that as long as everybody
trusts respect and love
doesn't matter what species they are
it's about the connection it's about the
communication
it's about the relationship trust
respect love so it doesn't matter what
species you are that's my point
yeah you know what i'm saying so it
doesn't matter what race you are what
religion you are what gender you are
if you're handicapped or not you know
handicapped people
make dogs normal because they give a dog
a job
normal people make dogs handicapped
because they don't give them a job
interesting you see what i'm saying so
that so to me the most important part is
is can you create trust respect and love
with different species
yes i can yes i can of course i can i
just did
you know what i mean so it's so great
metaphor that's right so it doesn't
matter what religion you are what gender
you are
what age you are what matter is can you
can you
align yourself with calmness confidence
love and joy
and if you do and then those people who
are in the same frame of mind
no matter what race they are you're
gonna click you're going to become a
pack
i think you'd be a good president for
the united states
i think we need someone like that listen
a great president a great speechwriter
one yeah
you know you know you got you know you
know i know you feel i know you don't
you know you talk about nobody you know
you have to be you feel you know that
you're
navigated by something yes of course of
course of course
and all the all the cameras look not
here you know you got something else
navigating without a doubt you're not
doing this [ __ ] by yourself no
okay yeah i know i'm not i'm not smart
enough to put myself where i am now
somebody's helping me that's right
and i'll tell you one thing look at this
i'm going to jump on that mic
i'm going to jump on that because i'm
going to tell you how i chose the coyote
so
you have a spirit of spiritual coyotes
you have emotional coyotes and you have
physical coyotes so when you jump the
border you
you you have to hire somebody because
you i didn't know
you know anything about america and how
it was just a dream
i needed to go to america and i had an
i didn't speak the address and my dad
gave me a hundred dollars that was his
life savings
okay so at two weeks i wanted to keep
that hundred dollars i had it in my my
between my
my sock and my and my shoe and
and for two weeks i i that's all i did
jump jump jump jump jump jump jump and i
get caught every single time every
single time
and then one day this guy comes skinny
guy smoke joint
dirty skinny everything my mom said not
to follow
something inside of me and say follow
him and the guy said i charge you a
hundred dollars
who sent it you know what i mean then on
top of that what's this
we crossed the border and he said well
you have to have a tax you have to catch
a taxi
so he can take you to san diego because
it's just the border right there san
ysidro right there
and they say i don't have any more money
after this the guy
paid the taxi
the guy paid twenty dollars that's and
that's when when i wrote my first book
i i said the angels that you can see
yeah
you know what i mean the second was jada
pink smith right because she paid
for me to learn english that's how i
learned english
wow so i so with my broken english at
that time i told jada
you know i would like to have a tv show
or radio because i want to teach people
right i saw the need of teaching right
so i never teach before
i didn't came to america to teach but i
felt free and comfortable to tell jada
i would like to have a tv show or radio
show well for that you need to speak
english
the next day a teacher came for a year
so i can learn english
those are angels that you can see
absolutely yeah without a doubt
without a doubt but i'm not here because
it's just me i'm here because
i follow that voice you know and and uh
and i'm i'm my fate is super big
the beautiful part about being poor is
that you pray every day
because government doesn't help you so
god is the only one who's going to be
there
you love the family to death and you
work hard
so my instincts high level my love high
level my faith high level
so that's that's what pushed me so
you're not poor anymore do you still
pray
of course yeah really because i want
world transformation
you know what i mean so i have a tag now
is better humans better planet
my goal now is not to become the best
doctor in the world my world my
is to educate the whole world yeah the
whole world
there is three kinds of people mike in
the dog world people who love dogs
people who are afraid of dogs and people
who
who hate dogs and i can train them all
because it's not about a dog it's about
that it's about the energy that you
people who are afraid of americans are
the 27th most happiest people in the
world you know
27. who's the first mexican
everybody a lot that's what's the
tequila
that's not happiness why are you playing
it that's the happiness the netherlands
is number one
yeah i can see why you know you smoke a
lot of weed that's why nah but you know
they they do what they
taxes are paid for yeah yeah yeah and
everything
it's a social it's more it's more
communist than anything but they don't
say those words
but they still have problems with dogs
mike i go to
the netherlands a lot look you've got
two in this class in this whole thing
yeah this is how it goes dude
yeah yeah yeah
so you i said mao that was a that was um
freudian slip
because you have a tattoo of mom oh my
shoulder yeah
i don't have tattoos this thing is my
tattoo
to the earth this is it my dpc
this is my tattoo to earth there you go
you know
symbolism formula rituals and symbols
oh everything about me go about my
insecurities my tattoos
my clothes everything i'm such a little
insecure guy
that's where i come from not now yes but
it's still it never goes away yeah yeah
yeah yeah you manage it now no
this is what some people understand
poverty never goes away i don't know how
much money you ever get
yeah it doesn't go away yeah and um
you're thinking money's gonna solve
everything you can't solve that your
poverty
your degree of poverty blows your mind
look how much money you get just blows
your mind
this isn't good yeah
but i didn't make that one so that is a
good one this is a good one good
but go for it i think one of the reasons
why so many people gravitate towards
mike is
he's not afraid to be
truthful with himself and and
transparent
you know to say those things that he
just said well that's calm surrender
very few people killed yeah that's kind
of surrender yeah right that's that
that's cancer it does come surrenders i
mean you have
a good side and you have you're not good
side and if you're comfortable with that
and you're able to speak you motivate
and inspire more people
that if you try to hide things right
because right now the world
in my opinion my humble opinion they
need to hear
males and females talk about both sides
the yin and yang
yeah right so you need to speak about
your light and your dark
right you need to speak about both and
your weakness and your strength
because everybody talks about strength
but that's not real
we didn't set the whole entire planet to
be the fact that the planet is polluted
that just shows you that we they would
just if we do that to
earth we do it to ourselves right the
greatness of a nation that is more
progress can be measured by the ways
animals are treated that's gandhi
right so the way you treat the planet
and the way you treat animals that's how
you treat yourself by my friend
so so the uh in denial in the animal
wars called avoidance
war in the middle east is called fight
not dealing with your own self
that's flight so the world lives more in
a fight flight avoidance than a
surrender state i told you earlier the
most
powerful state of mind you have as you
come surrender
right because this is where you you
assess and evaluate self
home family world um by the way
do you you have cbd treats for dogs is
that true that's what we're trying to do
oh yes we do yes
yes how does that so
how does it work for instance my dogma
is here that you've been he gets on a
plane
we get him on a plane and he just freaks
he can't deal with he's almost like
having
a heart attack you know he gets really
high attention when he gets in the plane
even even though you know you're a big
baller we're talking about a private
plane mike i hate to doubt you
yeah so your dog's on a private plane
yeah they don't know you don't know that
yeah
we're not talking about we're not
talking about spirit airlines
we're talking about a private plane with
mike tyson still panicking that's
interesting
yeah that's why some of the great
warrior leaders they
they always had some slaves say hey
you're just human that was their job
and not god you're just human that was
just this god
said this ruler you're not god you're
human
to bring it back to earth we get carried
away sometimes ground
yeah that's right that's why you need
animals
because they keep you grounded yeah
right stay grounded stay connected
right you know so so so you always have
that connection
it's about being connected that's what
adam we need animals we need plants we
need crystals
right did you have anyone in your
entourage that gave it to you straight
and that kept you grounded back in the
day or no
listen if customizer didn't tell me
nothing it didn't mean nothing
that's how i lived my life say it again
if my mentor didn't tell me nothing that
mean nothing
okay simple
[Music]
to me i just have so many animals that
immediately at the moment i change that
like
the bird changes you know the emo
changes the dog changes the turtle
changes whatever i have i had a kangaroo
changes so they keep you like stay
grounded
stay focused and exercise every day eat
healthy every day
you know check who you hang out with
every day you know
to be to be where i am it's just a lot
of people that
around us right you got the steak was
there ever a species that you witnessed
and you went
this is some one species i don't know if
i would be able to it's the personality
not the species yeah
i wouldn't think that too there's a
certain species that got more umph than
this guy but his
personalities like us huh
yeah animals i'm okay with it yeah
sometimes you could even like if you
were to encounter a silverback ape
you you did that you would be okay with
the silverback ape so once you do
ayahuasca you're gonna have your your
spirit animals coming in
oh [ __ ] yeah a gorilla came on then yeah
so that was your spirit animal the other
day yeah okay
interesting i don't mind i don't know
why i just said
i don't mind that's beautiful you have
to be guided you know what i mean
something has to guide you sometimes
it's people sometimes it's
intuition sometimes situations and
sometimes it's
it's just that particular animal like
daddy for example you know my pit bull
daddy
that guy guided me through the worst
time of my life
you know to the worst 16 years that guy
was right
there was a pit bull who helped me raise
my two kids who helped me go through the
whole entire
16 this first 16 years of my life in
america
and it's because of him the guidance
i'll tell you a story about this guy
before he passed away so that's so you
can see how in tune this guy was okay
so i'm going uh i was filming uh dog
whisper
and and this belgian malinois
developed fear for people okay
and but the dog was trying to find cell
phones in jail
okay yeah cell phones yes they somehow
they
somehow cell phones enter into jail okay
so this guy will find you know what
smells it finds it
and uh well he became afraid of people
so when i went
when i went to see evaluate this dog
this dog was
under a table and the the trainer
and the owner of the dog couldn't get
him out i couldn't get him out and i
said you know what there's only one
one guy who can get him out and my dog
was in my rv at that time
so i went to the rv he was waiting at
the door
he got out of the rv he
we never been in that place before he
went
he navigated touched the dog nose that
dog came back
and followed him to the rb how did you
explain that
wow how do you explain that that's he's
he's you know he's an alien he's like
you know spirit animal
yeah you know what i mean he's special
that that is special that's why he has
all this
i'm a strong believer that the dog is in
the bear family everybody knows at the
same nose
i was around the bear before a grizzly
bear
kodiak and i thought no the dog knows
there's no shape the same
the same the nose yeah the nose is super
powerful that's why you don't have to
touch talk let the nose do the work
sixty percent of the brain reaction is
controlled by the nose
the nose is their eye so the dog the dog
born blind and death
and when he dies he or he's a before he
dies
blind in death but he never loses his
nose
nose eyes ears no size ears so
that's why i always say no touch no talk
no eye contact let the dog come to you
let him smell you
let it feel your energy then he will
remember your scent and your energy so
your scent is your name and your energy
is your last name
and then from that point on he will
remember the rest of his life
in a good way calm
you want to be calm claim your space
come confident and that from that point
on you can gain his stress and respect
wow that's good stuff man
this is amazing i'm freaking out over
here
i'm starting to think about my dog my
dog this this is what my dog does to me
every every night every moment what is
this
he would lick on me all night my dog was
like if i listen to this look at the top
of my head and my hands after
he touched some food he would just lick
on me all night don't stop
my wife you just won't stop unless my
wife make him stop i like it a lot but
my wife
well it's definitely grooming healing
you know it's just soothing you so there
is
there is a reason for it but there's
also limits so you can have limits to
how long can they do it
they do it among each other but once the
other one is done he
that's it so they know that it's limits
but if you don't they just get if
especially they're having drain energy
so if the dog has a drain energy
properly the dog is going to
bark the dog is going to leak the dog is
going to chew the dog's going to dig
so the dogs are barking at the window
you know when your neighbors complain
what the dog is doing is draining his
energy
because normally they don't bark that
long so barking is communication but
they know they're not supposed to do it
for a long period of time
so the only reason why they do it for a
long period of time is because they
haven't drained the physical energy
so that becomes an outlet if dogs can
smoke or drink
and america will be a lot of dogs
smoking and drinking because they had
nothing else to do
what are you doing nothing man i'm just
gonna have a drink right i haven't
drained my energy my mind is not
occupied so there will be a lot of dogs
smoking and drinking in america
if they were doing it you know it's
interesting mike brought up bears
did you know that when um
when a bear eats human food
it forgets how to go back into the
stream and catch
fish for himself are you serious it
doesn't it no longer
it gives up all those ways and now it
just wants
it's just going to come and beg for food
it's such a trip
that's what they say never feed the
bears huh yeah because they'll just keep
coming back
that's the better in the wild also the
the guys who go on the trash can and
stuff like that that's why you see these
bears
trying to get into your home that's in
alaska it's a sweet it's like having a
sugar daddy yeah you just become
dependent on that sugar daddy also we
we eat a lot of sugars so you know what
i mean most of the stuff there's a lot
of sugars
they get it you know what i mean so they
get addicted like ice cream
any kind of ice cream that's vanilla ice
cream
yeah and cooking cream too whatever it
was licked it licked it looked like a
hole
[ __ ] addictive yeah it's sugar
biggest drug in the world indeed
yeah biggest drug in the world i think
the biggest narcotic in the world is
just cameras i think that beats sugar
what do you think uh you know
yes i think that it has been a downfall
yeah great smart people
just couldn't stop loving himself too
much hmm
i see because there's something not
natural about it it's not
it's not i'm sleepy like what we're
supposed to have this conversation
yeah but it's just supposed to be the
three of us hanging out we're not
supposed to document
and put it all over the world and then
someone's saying oh man caesar's right
and i think that was cool and somebody
said yeah look he said i look good today
so i'm gonna do this and i made me look
better it's good this is a drug man i
got
so caught up with this stuff almost
killed myself you imagine
thinking tell me about that just
thinking i was somebody really special
oh you know i'm really really thinking
really special and
i had to have um what's that [ __ ] called
preferential but how do they say like
preferential treatment that's the right
word yeah that worked i was
thinking i had to do that stuff man you
oh man you know i had to be beaten in
submission
you know when you there were submission
i had to be beaten in submission
i didn't give up that you know i'm hard
to give up i'm not a quitter that's
right
i'm not a quitter and man you had to tap
out
if i wanted to live in that world stay
in that world yeah
yeah tap out that's big right there you
learned some great lessons
but they were hard lessons yeah but i
rather learned something they never
learned them at all yeah
oh man [ __ ] life is beautiful i never
saw it
thought of it that way that's a that's a
drug
oh absolutely the biggest you have a
chance to see yourself the way you want
to see yourself
can you imagine that power to actually
see yourself the way your ego wants you
to be seen
can you imagine that power you could
some people can't even think you might
start thinking about it now
can you imagine to look like you want to
look in your mind and your heart and
your whole soul
to think that the whole world might love
you even
just you could never you could never be
too light you could never be too proud
you can never be too short you can never
nothing that you're fluffy and
it's crazy spanish can never be
everything you have all your flaws
it's just everything that makes you
excel
imagine that all your flaws is just
everybody else's best day
yeah i give you back to that
it gives the promise of immortality if
your flaws is everybody else's best day
exactly oh wow i wasn't thinking like
that
i never thought of it that way that's my
biggest lesson right now that's amazing
imagine but you've you've navigated this
and you've stayed true to yourself you
know it's not like you're a different
guy
than you were you know before you had
the show
and after it's not you're the same guy
no i just speak better in english
and i just explain things clear okay
but uh the the mexican guy the
hard-working guy the spiritual guy the
guy who loves his mom and his family
uh his country and and the opportunities
and the world
and and just changing the world that's
still the same way so that's why i never
saw it that way i saw it
as this is one way to help the world you
know what i mean
because to me i just want to make sure
the animals have a safe peace and love
environment
they accomplish exactly what they could
accomplish without us trust respect love
and for people to really imitate honest
integrity loyalty
you know this is the pack code this is
the pursuit of happiness this is living
in the moment
this is unconditional love you know they
don't have a problem
using their body to to do it you know
they live or die baby live or die it's
all about the pack
i just think um the animals are born
stuff to take care of them i guess
that's what i believe
because if they want we'd be just
hunting them hunting them down that's
what i what they still do you know but
that's just i think that would be just
the thing it's on these things and
they're meant to be hunted
yeah and um we all have at maybe some
point we thought about that because we
were in that
you know that we were just in that field
in order to think that we were around
those kind of people
and as you learn compassion and you
learn um
sympathy and fatigue compassion and all
that once you learn
i don't care who you can still be a
scumbag but once you learn that
things change yes sir you used to just
change
but that's my mission in the world to
trigger that empathy and compassion
you know what i mean to trigger that
even for the people who love dogs
like i said three kinds of people in the
world so you you will experience you
will experience people that love you
people are afraid of you people who
don't like you
so you're gonna experience those three
energies you see what i'm saying so
for me the goal is how do i take away
your fear from dogs and you dislike from
dogs because it's best for that for you
not to live with it
i'm not telling you to adopt a dog to
get a dog i'm not i'm just telling you
to get rid of fear
to get rid of hate it's not healthy for
your family
there's just gonna always be people not
like dogs it's just gonna always be like
that
and that's what we have to do as people
learn to live in that sphere
yeah we have to learn that thank god
everybody in this world
don't think the same way i think thank
god they don't think the way i think
and that's why we have to we have to um
we have to work with the
um with the objectives that we everybody
don't think like we do
we have to live with the fact that
things that we don't necessarily
understand
we have to live with well that's what we
have to start with next generation which
is the children
because they don't know uh uh anything
else except whatever
they they learn whatever energy they
feel
you know whatever they get influenced so
if we teach them at our early age to
hear trust respect love honesty interior
loyalty
exercise discipline affection rules mind
limitation front of the pack mirror the
pack back of the pack
whatever you fit in the pack you were
born for it and you're going to be the
best out of it
because we need you in the pack you know
what i mean nobody has
as special it's just you were born for
that position
but we just have to make sure we nurture
your strength your skills
right so you feel special exactly
like when you were 13 you went to your
mom and you said this is my plan she
could have said
you're crazy but when i was 10 when i
was 10 i live in you know
cancer in mexico so when i was 10 i went
to my mom and said
i went and said i'm going to be a drug
dealer you know and my mom pass slappy
okay
if you want to kill me that's what you
do and i didn't know
that you know it's just everybody around
me all the cartels are there
you know so we don't have only one pablo
scobar we have ten
okay so our our movie stars are
carteles okay so so
so that's what you look into and so on i
was 10 i said that
and my mind said no and then when i was
13 after watching last year in 19
i said mom you think i'd be the best
doctor in the world nobody ever wanted
to be the best doctor in the world
you know but when when i said with such
a conviction
and there was nothing to do with drug
dealers she said you can be whatever you
want
that was it and that was powerful damn
baby that was it that was
my mom believed in me i believe it and
of course god already believed it so we
were the triangle
you know and i learned this from my dad
but if i were to tell my dad dad you
think i could be the
trainer he said get a better job i
learned this from my dad and my
grandfather
yeah how not to work against mother
nature that was my grandfather my dad
because we
i grew up on a farm and my grandfather
you know
he died 105. he never went to school so
it was instinctual
instinctual instinctual but look what i
learned
yeah you know what i mean so i learned
respect honor
you know love to the family hard work
integrity
loyalty all of that comes from those two
guys
but the belief comes from my mom
you know so the hard work and the whole
pack code that's my
as my grandpa my dad the whole
instinctual thing
liver died protection direction not them
but they believe in the and the passion
and condition of love that's my mom
so i got that but thanks god i told my
mom that
because she didn't hesitate to say you
can be whatever you want
right that's what i wanted to be a the
best doctor in the world
over there you couldn't dream to be a an
astronaut or
or a fireman like kids do here or a
police officer like you don't want to do
that
over there you know astronauts no way in
the world
it's my experience i believe in the
power of belief i've been always a
student to
in the power of belief and i've always
been successful in believing yep even
whatever it was whether good or was it
bad i believed it that's right
that's right that's that's that's
exactly that's exactly right you can be
a bad person and and good at it
you know but that has to do a lot with
who's who's guiding you
yeah you know who's who's your parents
you know who's who's your role model
because
you don't know right from wrong you just
want to be the best look at this
what is that who's that that's diana and
the anna's
my pirate parrot oh there you go
diana she's beautiful isn't she yeah
oh i think she likes you don't you gotta
loosen up
oh my goodness i'll be tense right oh my
goodness i want you to relax
turn around you never look at you dude
there's my handsome boy right there
morocco
[Music]
she's a sweetheart she's very gentle in
it
yeah yeah that's right
yeah yeah she likes that
that was amazing that was an incredible
hot boxing session with cesar milan and
uh and my guy mike tyson
i'm here uh i mean my god it's just the
beginning but we're honored to have you
man
thank you appreciate it thank you glad
to talk we talk about animals we talk
about
the motor code what empathy compassion
what animals can do for for our world
better humans better planet
yeah so happy to share it with you guys
yeah welcome to the ranch you guys are
more than welcome to come back
you just do with that cameras yes yes
ourselves yes this is just the beginning
thank you guys for joining us
thank you
you